1300 enmiendas presentadas para este
proyecto de ley sobre la seguridad
global 32 artículos que prevén en
particular más misiones para la policía
municipal más regulación de la seguridad
privada y la creación de un marco legal
para la vigilancia policial por medio de
drones el artículo 24 que trata de la
difusión de imágenes de policías creará
un nuevo delito si se adopta difundir
por cualquier medio y sobre cualquier
soporte con el fin de causar daños
físicos o psicológicos a su integridad
física o psíquica la imagen del rostro o
cualquier otro elemento de
identificación de un funcionario de la
policía nacional o de un miembro de la
gendarmería nacional cuando actúe en el
marco de una operación policial sanción
por este nuevo delito un año de prisión
y una multa de 45.000 euros
creed y zetas cual es el propósito de
este artículo y proteger a los agentes
de policía que a veces son víctimas de
amenazas o agresiones pero sin
prohibición de filmar quiero ser claro
fue este caso para ningún límite para la
grabación de acciones policiales
entonces pero se podría buscar justicia
si se comprueba que la difusión de las
imágenes tuvo la intención de dañar los
sindicatos de periodistas denuncian un
intento de socavar la libertad de
información para las asociaciones que
hacen campaña contra la violencia
policial es una forma de limitar la
publicación de estas imágenes videos que
a veces pueden ser utilizados como
prueba cuando los funcionarios de la ley
están implicados a petición de la liga
de derechos humanos las naciones unidas
han publicado un informe sobre el
proyecto de ley y considera que pueden
conducir a la violación de las
libertades fundamentales